when I found out that the park is being
rated I had just come from a council
meeting off site but for the for the
General Assembly and I was absolutely in
shock brokenhearted and then I just got
so incredibly angry at the injustice
that is happening here they threw out
5,000 books they took medical supplies
they through people's
tense everything's the dumpsters as
watching this and now they're claiming
there's like a warehouse that people can
get it and it's like soy disrespectable
and it's also illegal so Facebook has
been amazing actually knew about this
because of Facebook guys going to bed at
midnight and I took my phone and like
you know there were Twitter and Facebook
accounts and said like there's a raid
you know we have a great team of people
here they're very savvy about using
social media and coordinating things so
you know we've had eyes in the courts
room we've had eyes up in the canal
street 6ab where we had a contingent
there we've had people down here we're
all in connecting you know wrong contact
with each other through social medias
right now I'm live streaming I worked
and i went with media the immediate
working group in the occupation I'm just
basically streaming leo what's going on
here today waiting on the court order
waiting on there were folks from the COI
see what's going to go down because it
will be epic day we have one of the
lawyers from the National Lawyers Guild
and part of the legal team that was
before the courts this morning seeking a
temporary restraining order against the
city interfering with people being able
to go back into the park the judge just
ruled in our favor allowing us to go
back into the park okay but it still we
don't know if NYPD is going to comply
they seem intent on breaking the law
rather than upholding the law what
they've been sworn to a pole eastern
corners the Easter quarters are
organizing are organizing meetings to
decide meetings to decide what to do
next what to do if we can't we can't get
back into the park we just got word that
they're going to start letting people
into the North bursar the East End of
the park very few people just little by
little they're going to open up one gate
we can't stay here overnight which i
think is fair and that's pretty much
what I expected to happen hopefully we
can still maintain Zuccotti Park as a
base of operations because we're really
we love this place like we've had a lot
of victories here this is sort of the
home of the Occupy Wall Street movement
now it's a global movement but this is
this is our base of operations we love
this space and so it is it's a it's a
really nice victory I think that we that
we at least get that tenuous little grip
on it we keep waiting
Oh
yup
you